this is the dollop on the all things
comedy Network now see you're a guy you
just a guy and it's saying what is this
guy got well say you went to say you
went Europe sure and you know you walked
in front of a queen when you shouldn't
have right the princess didn't want to
meet with you and yet you [ __ ] you talk
[ __ ] to the Prime Minister about what
she should do and and and say you used
just blatantly Nazi language fascist
language sharad immigrants in Europe
sure so this hypothetical guy said I
really think if you're that kind of guy
you should talk to a therapist cuz you
got some issues
sounds like other people have issues and
I think I'm fine I recommend talk space
oh it's an online therapy company lets
you message a licensed therapist from
anywhere at any time so even if you're
making a total ass out of yourself in
England you can still text yeah it's a
different time got a texting machine on
hand you certainly got a Twitter means a
[ __ ] what's up all you need is a
computer and internet connection and or
the talk space mobile app it means you
can improve your mental health even if
you've had trouble making it time for it
in the past which you cleave if you're
this kind of gentleman you clearly have
had a lot of is this the kind of guy
who's maybe doing it on the toilet yeah
I mean yeah I mean he's probably on the
toilet a lot so this is probably good
for him right okay
you know therapy is very important a lot
of people need it my wife's therapist
you need it so much you married oh I
married one and and the the the talk
space app a lot of people have been
helped we've got a lot of messages by
people saying this has helped them
because there's a lot of people that
don't have access to what we have here
in Los Angeles which is 1,500,000
therapists one per Starbucks one per
Starbucks
so remember therapy isn't just about
venting your innermost thoughts or
digging into your childhood memories
it's also about practical everyday
strategies for stress management and
living a happier life one way is to not
be a Nazi having a therapist simply
provides you with a designated person
for you to talk to who is trained to
listen and to help you make positive
changes positive changes positive like I
should shove the Queen okay
the tax base but who was that you may
have did a voice it's me yeah I'm just
dumb time by the random guy
oh it's random the tax based platform
has over 2,000 licensed therapists who
are experienced in addressing life
challenges that we all face to match for
the perfect therapist for a fraction of
the price of traditional therapy go to
talk space.com slash dollop and use the
code dollop to get forty five dollars
off your first month and show your
support for this show that's table and
talk space.com slash dollop which is of
course an american history podcast each
week i Dave Anthony read a story from
American history to a guy that I've met
okay his name is Gareth Reynolds who has
no idea what the topic is going to be
about because he's lazy
yes he would know yep that's right if I
tried and now we have a special
heart condition now in the bloody you
both present sick arguments
[Music]
Gareth Dave we have you and I'll be on a
show here it's a title comedy versus
displacement it is a benefit for the
Glendale tenants Union this Tuesday 17th
at 8:00 p.m. it's me you Jackie Kashian
Moshe kasher James Adomian
Adam Todd Brown and Josh Adamski's been
added and I'm probably not a couple more
but that's Tuesday that is at the anteus
theater 110 east broadway glendale APM
nice see everyone there and Dave we
should point out that we have a lovely
guest in studio today yeah Pam Reynolds
joining the dollop again mother hello
Dave hello coffee Karen Murphy just no
name how about no name no no I can't
call you no name that's not fair enough
Pam will be our guest on the dog door in
Salt Lake City yeah this Friday the 20th
at the complex and Denver on the 21st at
gates concert all actually our guests we
will announce we went will i
understanded those two shows we're very
happy to have him he's a big star he's
sucking a big big funny guy and we enjoy
him yeah we've invited super creepy
waving the same you know just the way
you're kind of putting it super weird
obviously I'm so good at all Podcast
calm you can get tickets area plus we've
got tons of other tickets Australia
shows are now on sale but there is a
whole gigantic lineup you can go check
out see we've just added in new york
city so get on it people that's where
they make that good salsa oh yeah that's
my guy he's not a good guy go what nice
date okay I'll do my dad's Dave I'll be
in st. Louis at helium comedy club July
26th through the 28th I'll be at the
punchline in San Francisco when from
August 1st through August 4th or sorry
August 2nd throw
fourth I'll be at helium in Portland
August 9th through August 11th and then
we'll be in Minneapolis on August 16th
then we'll also be in Nashville
August 18th and then the following night
I'll be at stand-up live in Huntsville
Alabama Sunday August 19th at 7 o'clock
portland alabama you me
we'll see if i let you do all those ok
are also sponsored by ritual now my wife
and I we have a baby but before we had a
baby have a baby you had a baby we have
a son we had we had one now he's a kid
yeah he's in Ireland but uh he's in
Ireland is that okay yeah yeah we sent
him to Ireland yeah yeah he's fine
you've heard the podcast right yeah but
there's leprechauns of stuff there it's
like a fairyland okay you just send can
you attest to that is in Dublin yeah oh
yes yeah so uh so we had trouble headin
if you notice we had trouble having our
kid so when you do that everyone starts
freaking out about what you're putting
in your body sure such as vitamins you
know you start when you're you're like
you you start wondering as a lady what
you put your body sure what's happening
right now
well ritual is a vitamin supplement okay
and a woman uh she she she was trying to
get pregnant and she was like what's all
this stuff we started reading
ingredients she's like this isn't good
in the vitamins she was taking yeah
because you don't know what's really in
there vitamins are kind of a bit of a
scattershot with a lot of stuff so she
started checking out what was in there
and she then she met with some experts
and said let's make some stuff that is
clean good and it has crazy enough vegan
sugar-free non-gmo gluten-free allergen
free without synthetic fillers or
colorings like all like the stuff you
want when you put your body
why not yeah good stuff right right
right how about that right but this is
the kind of stuff that my wife was
looking for when when we were trying to
have a kid because you're trying to you
know be healthy yeah yeah they got
delayed released capsule that bypasses
the stomach to help with nausea because
that's actually my I always do vitamins
on an empty stomach and then I want to
vomit like I'm healthy I've got to go
throw up my vitamins
they're mint scented with an in bottled
tab enriched with pure peppermint oil so
you don't have vitamin breath yeah
that's right walking around like yeah
yeah yeah just a little zinc this is all
zinc at you patent-pending technology
and formulation so go there website and
you learn everything from why each
ingredient is beneficial to where it's
sourced um it's uh it's a
subscription-based $30 a month deliver
your door.you by Omega 3 yourself is the
cost buying omega-3 just on its own as
the cost of a ritual bottle so fill the
gaps in your diet with the best sourced
ingredients happiness guaranteed no
questions asked cancel easily at any
time are you in oh I'd like to be happy
there we go yeah I mean yeah well I
might get there sometime yeah 95% women
do not give the vitamins and minerals
they need on a daily basis ritual
created a smarter vitamin with the nine
essential ingredients women lack the
most Wow yeah so it's not for you I see
oh yeah I love for you I will take it
okay part of my ritual go to ritual calm
slash dollop choose clean ingredients
which are backed by science they went
the whole route on this thing those are
the guys who are telling us that global
warming doesn't exist how come it's
snowing new your own Oh welcome New York
have snow sign up now at ritual calm
slash dollop I care they have something
else exciting to tell you about okay
they least people call this up and they
said it would this be for garrus garrus
garrus do you know my name garfi Oh Dave
thank you
besides it is going to call third love
brought third love bra which you need
sure and we I'm talking to you about
this for a while for this important well
first you where you know we let you we
let you have a third love bra for a week
is where yeah and it's a perfect fit
right yeah it was great yeah yeah using
thousands of real women's measurements
third love designs as bras with breast
size and shape in mind so they fit
impeccably and feel even better
is that your experience yeah no it was
good cuz I was like this is for sure
fitting my yes yeah and then I was like
oh yeah this is my kind of bra yeah
that's what I'm talking about
yeah quality in every stitch as you
could feel when you Ward around all day
yeah and I was getting a lot of looks
too so you know is a good bra yeah for
sure
well the details make the difference and
they have premium fabrics and in its
expert expertly designed but you know
I'm not to tell you let me tell you have
you thrown out all your other bras now
that's the let me put it this way it's
the only one I have are you wearing it
now mm-hmm that's for me to know and you
to find out I'd love has the most sizes
of any bra brand okay so you get the big
ones for you small ones for me cups a
through H bands up to 48 nice yeah we
talked about that earlier that you have
that you've gotten down to to a 36 yep
finally each size their design age yeah
my dream each side is designed
specifically for a perfect fit 50
percent of all women fall in between
standard cup sizes so they're love
invented 1/2 cup sizing boom okay
comfort and quality hands-down the most
comfortable ball you're gonna own it
tagless labels no itching which I know
you had a big problem with the other bra
I will say tags on anything I don't
understand
yeah get rid of them I agree that's why
well so yeah straps that won't slip
ultra soft smooth fabrics lightweight
super thin memory foam cops there love
knows there's a perfect bra for everyone
so right now they're offering our
listeners 50% off your first order go to
third love calm so I stop now to find
Hervey fitting bra get 50% off your
first purchase that's third love.com /
dollop for 50% off today
they did send my wife one and she's
enjoying it but also it's weird to walk
in and grill your wife about a bra so I
didn't do that she just said she liked
it would you like me to call her I don't
want you to feel uncomfortable
I'm already uncomfortable okay sure well
Pam do you know anything else dad I know
I didn't think so no no get one of those
bras very nice thank you thank you very
much how are things over and where you
from France okay
France who won the World Cup today
incidentally oh my boy is France your
boys here we go
Dave likes winners that's a proven
whoever's up top he's like uh-huh no I
want to Belgium to win but that wouldn't
happen yeah so um okay 500 BC what that
is that the earliest I've got yeah it
might be it's got to be climbed might be
well it's between 500 BC and 300 AD so
anywhere in there oh Christ
you know me I'm kind of a stickler for
that time so but we you know the Christ
had a bad time in there and that time
zone but mostly uh you know help the
time Roman stuff right okay a little bit
of Greek good guy the wandering womb
theory came to be okay this was the
belief that a displaced uterus was the
cause of many medical problems and women
have they tried ritual so I'm talking
about okay okay so okay if the uterus
moved up it would cause sluggishness a
lack of strength and vertigo
if the uterus moved up Evan went up in
the body right like you be dizzy really
lungs or whatever sure if the uterus hit
your lungs you'd be tired you know your
Virgo you big I can't stand up my throat
again quote and the women is pained in
the veins on each side of the head okay
so I guess in get a headache
okay your uterus goes up you get a
headache so and how are they measuring
the uterus going up hmm how are they
aware that the uterus is going up they
do a poke or whatever they're just
poking and going like
this woman's uterus is up yeah all right
these are doctors they're old-timey
doctors those are the best kind
if the uterus went down there would be a
strong sense of choking a loss of speech
and sensibility and a very sudden
incredible death okay so if your uterus
goes down so if you just goes up you're
you dizzy and you don't really know what
you're saying and then if it goes down
you're probably gonna die check it out
right yeah okay I found that to be the
case definitely mine's going down right
now in an ancient Greek medical text
quote in the middle of the bodies of
women lies the womb a female organ oh my
closely resembling and resembling an
animal what animal a jellyfish for it
moves itself hither and thither in the
abdomen also upwards in a direct line to
below the throat okay so in doctors
speak
the woman has a sort of gazelle ish
piece of skin inside of her that is
moving up or down in origin Oregon and
it's moving all around and it's causing
her trauma in whichever way it
hokey-pokey that's correct right you're
basically a doctor right now hey I told
you to match the scientific I can tell
ya it also moves to the right or left
either to the liver or the spleen and it
likewise is subtending on who's got we
also Falls downwards and then a word it
is altogether erratic sure okay so
essentially wombs are vibrating their
Loose Cannons right okay and they're
just sort of bouncing around yeah like
or not they should have been tethered
but apparently they weren't right so
it's just basically the woman's organs
are a pinball machine and the womb is
the pinball that's right right okay it
delights also in fragrant smells and
advances important them okay so so if it
sounds something nice the uterus will go
for it sure so like you know take if you
take brownies out of the oven yeah
oh he must smell the cookies
yeah that's total uterus okay coming up
to get the smell yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no just the hand comes out of don't
forget a microphone going down it's
right it has an aversion to foul smells
sure and fleas from them and on the
whole the womb is like an animal within
an animal right so the sorry just to be
clear ant other animal is the Yemen yes
okay so the uterus yeah animal within
the woman who's also an animal yeah
okay so naturally no one challenged this
brilliant idea for centuries and
eventually it found its way to a place
called America okay good that got
exported doesn't surprise me by the way
that's pretty much what 35% of the
country believes now and yeah right it
hasn't changed you know you keep that
away from her otherwise her wombs gonna
come out and bite your hand
don't take the brownies out I got to get
the ladies into the cellar oh no hurry I
hope but mrs. fields out now these women
are gonna be up all nights with their
animal wombs and their animal bodies
damn are you gonna kill my wife
shut that cellar door the uteri are
coming up from the book organ diseases
of women published in Philadelphia in
1877 light years at this point yeah I
mean we're finally some actual rational
thinking we're a good century and a half
along yeah oh sorry thousand 1500 years
long the virgin womb is a very small
affair what and keeps out of the way and
out of reckoning the normal virgin
uterus balloons about within the abdomen
out of harm's way it is light and Hollow
and so long as it is in this happy state
of unawakened life it is without trouble
and giving none okay
so we've gone from the uterus of being a
wild rabid dog to it now is basically
neo in the matrix
yeah yeah I mean if that's what you mean
by ballooning well it likes to stay out
of its way
you know if the uterus doesn't
understand its world then it just chill
that's right right
it's only when the organ gets ill
enlarged or displaced and thus
troublesome that it becomes the object
of medicine so wait wait only one like
so biggest problem Yeah right or moves
around like we talked about with the
Greeks or the Romans right then then
it's a problem okay right so in place
Wells that's a problem yeah it would
that not be the case with most things
that are in your body yeah but right
okay yep sure okay there were many
things that could be considered harmful
to the uterus doctors men a fall uh-huh
examples and I figured it was flubber in
examples included quote slipping on the
pavement on a piece of orange peel oh no
someone peeled an orange over here bingo
being thrown from a carriage sure oh now
there's a bunch of oranges the horses
and tripping while going down the stairs
though because those could all harm the
uterus right
those would harm again I feel like what
well why are we holding the uterus to
this specific spot lights nature is what
causes all of the things to happen is
that right yeah so it's sort of the Iron
Man heart yeah there are other things
like excessive and tiring walks long
mountain expedition sorry these are side
effects you don't know what what causes
the uterus to place okay I didn't Oh
medical experts say young women should
be gradually introduced so their wombs
could be accustomed to the harshness of
a tiring walk but even then it was
considered a great risk
but they've oh there's always been this
aversion to women walking yes it's just
another reason walk that means they're
going somewhere right someone's gonna
tell them something that they're not
supposed to know you'd be sitting down
on the couch put your fingers in your
ears until I talk again another Medical
Journal said wombs could be damaged from
climbing a hill now that means a room
within a person not just a womb directly
sort of the one
yeah yeah on its own right no no the
womb would not go out on its own it's
left me goodbye
up a towering mountain I love life also
dancing running jumping sneezing
coughing vomiting and holding children
in their arms okay so basically sitting
is what you should be doing that was
yeah unless you're sitting with a child
in your arms right Yeah right
we're sneezing uh-huh or throwing up or
coughing right don't get sick don't move
don't dance don't have fun don't go on
walks don't go in carriages don't use
the stairs it's pretty simple list one
doctor reported a case of a woman
slipping and falling which do so
dislocated the ovary okay see now we're
getting and I mean I can't poke holes
but dislocating it okay nope normal not
a thing not a thing okay
he's been the doctor just snaps it back
in place like Riggs from lethal weapon
sure mom you know what I'm talking about
the doctor operated and removed the
ovary other than having fallen he said
the ovary appeared healthy okay so once
he got the ovary out he's like hey what
do you know it's fine that looks great
all right well sorry but uh well it fell
well you took it out of me yeah you know
the problem is unfortunately yeah
someone removed your ovary that was you
and there's no coming back from that
well you did it so I hate to be the guy
who has to deliver the bad news but you
did the bad news you did the bad news
I'm gonna get you through this get me
through what the thing that you did I
too much we need to do is something
radical like you not be a doctor we have
to take the other over yeah are you a
doctor
no did you were you under the impression
I was a doctor yeah no no I'm an
aspiring basketball player I'm here to
see a doctor too but I just
what is basketball it's a game that it's
new something I'm tinkering around with
okay
anyway yeah yeah I've always wanted to
be a doctor did you leave did I leave
would you I won't okay I gotta see the
doctor but to kill time maybe I'd take
that other one out no we're good Oh
I've only got the let's watch him with
your eyes no okay
boy that'd be a great monster couldn't
you put the other that couldn't you put
that over here a kin if you're a doctor
that's amazing
David I'm gonna say no back then I'm
saying no I'm gonna say at this point
they just don't give a [ __ ] yeah that
they just won't try because they're just
like we got one out and all right sorry
lady shouldn't have been walking that's
right that was a bit of a punishment
really well well going to the doctor was
a bit of have you thought about not
being a lady yeah that's the problem and
there was no anesthetic was there nope I
just went surgery put it back in would
have really hurt oh yeah and you take it
out yeah there the whole thing's a
nightmare it's just it's been a
nightmare
compounding problem yeah uterus is are
also affected by exposure to cold or
sudden temperature change and so are
people and it got worse the mine cold
also damaged the uterus the mother mine
Cole well they call that the mine cold
quote does he mean coal mine morbid
irritation of the uterus is induced by
by sexual imaginings whether arising
spontaneously or generated by improper
and loose conversation by the reading of
romances novels plays or books still
more impure and by attendance at the
ballroom and the theater the amount of
control desired I mean just we've almost
covered everything someone can do yeah
so far literally again the only thing
you can do is sit and have your fingers
in your ears yeah so you can't talk
about sex you can't think about sex you
can't read about sex
anything about sex will cause you an
irritating around know my coughing no
coughing I would say no oranges because
it sounds like they're just leaving
hazards all over the place so the sex
the reading and learning about sex stuff
was bad for the whole woman's
you see a car that's the uterus okay
it made the brain sensitive and
irritable the uterus was the most
irritated but sexual thoughts quote the
uterus especially it becomes morbidly
excitable okay so so the you know when
you when you start talking about when
you start thinking about sexual thoughts
your uterus goes [ __ ] [ __ ] your
uterus like Casper the ghost yes so it
is a living breathing being yeah look
the animal like your name like a wild
animal I'm sorry it's like a dog inside
of you that knows English and is horned
up that's it and that's what your uterus
is and the second that it hears anything
ribald or sexual well guess what it
wants to come out and party and then
when it's out it's smoking cigarettes
it's looking to do bumps oh yeah oh yeah
it's looking to part a turn and don't
let it find another uterus yeah cuz then
you're gonna have two uteri that's right
it's [ __ ] their brains out and then
all of a sudden they're thinking about
sex and then they're gonna have a baby
uterus wait and then all these
eventually gonna have to go back inside
of you woman all because you wanted to
think about a dick so you're a doctor
again I'm inventing basketball ever I'm
not misleading you I've been carry up
keep going on about uterus inside I love
the things I keep thinking you might be
a dying ran away when I was a kid okay
and I had a beautiful uterus in my yard
I want to move on with my story I used
to give it fish in it also sitting was
bad for the uterus okay so now you
you're allowed to hover in a sort of
float like state waters good for you
just floating in water for the rest of
your life could be the move turned out
things like long continued use of a
sewing machine and playing the piano
would cause wound problems so moving and
not moving we're problems right so your
option is basically await your death
from your uterus yeah yeah okay so
obviously all these issues made
transportation a problem oh god yeah
horses must have been considered to be
like a womb apocalypse if you think
about it okay
right sidesaddle was considered the only
except acceptable way for a woman to run
since the 1300s because of the belief
that riding a stride would break the
hymen and then they'd have all kinds of
uterus problems had they ever thought
about letting a woman do things and then
finding out what happened what like
didn't hear me out because I know
understand oh no this doesn't make sense
hear me out cuz I know this sounds crazy
but instead of just assuming that every
time a woman right was on a horse that
her hymen was gonna break right maybe
let a woman ride a horse
you lost me okay so and I understand
this is heavy uh-huh so instead of just
assuming that something bad is going to
happen if a woman gets on a horse yeah
yeah you know because again you have a
you know if you're picturing this you
probably have a penis and you don't know
what if they do yeah yeah and so you're
just assuming that the woman is going to
just shatter her hymen or that her womb
is gonna you know come out of her mouth
and just start to you know take the
stirrups I just want to see her yeah
hemorrhaging yeah why not they just let
her ride the horse are you lost me so
okay so let her ride the horse for a
little while what happen break some
litter on the horse and see what
happened you lost me but put her on the
horse let her go on the were trying to
protect her from me I understand but
instead of protecting or see what
happens why don't you know just sort of
try it with one woman I'm gonna stall
put one woman on but I my what I'm gonna
do is call the police if you continue
okay yeah no I just yeah that's crazy I
know it's crazy yeah well I've been
drinking like you might be a witch so a
woman had to ride sidesaddle which meant
she could not apply leg pressure to the
horse or signal with her thighs knees or
heels she do not drop her hands to turn
or stop a runaway horse sure so it looks
right again
look great you look [ __ ] awesome and
then the hymens fine and the uterus is
all good yeah don't try to control the
horse just let it do its thing till it's
that's right the horses horse right
around now you try anything too
dangerous your uterus is gonna come out
again a typical accident was written up
in the Baltimore Star quote a young
woman received an injury in the field
that may make her a [ __ ] for life
the sidesaddle she was riding carried
her under her horse when it fell down
her spine was injured and her condition
was so critical that for several days
she was not removed from a kitchen table
in a farmhouse to which she was
after the accident riding experts agreed
that the lady had the lady been astride
she would have fallen clear of her horse
and might even with her great control
have held the animal from falling okay
so she would have been fine but also but
here's the thing I just I just need to
bring up sure her hymen would have been
[ __ ] up we don't what about a uterus
yeah I mean all bad everything up in
that spot yeah it's always better that
she can't walk
can I just okay two things the hymen is
still good two things one is the best
place for someone who's just been
trampled by a horse a kitchen table yeah
well how else is she gonna eat when
dinner put her to bed how she can eat
fair pushback absolutely
okay point two um why not just let her
do what she wants and then some sorry
you asked me to the fact that she would
be okay I heard you say do what let her
ride the horse yeah I don't because then
she can stop it and then she's not gonna
fall underneath the horse right but
thinner what's happening to her hymen I
mean but again I don't think we know
that what's happening to her huh I think
we do we've never seen it because we've
always just said shoot so you would like
her to be an unmarried woman with
possibly dying from her uterus bobbing
around that would that's your answer
we're taking some leaps mmm the woman's
handbook in health and disease in 1886
said a violent exercise on horseback or
in a wagon without Springs caused eater
and damage it occurred our women are
women buying into this are women women
no women are like this is ridiculous
okay
sure if it occurred well some are but
most aren't okay if it occurred
treatment was complete rest of mind and
body right so if you had a uterus
problem that you complete rest okay
quote the woman should remain quietly in
bed sure well it's interesting - feels
like you're adding subtly subtly one
additional extra word is an additional
note in there yes she must rest and shut
up what'd she do wasn't you just sitting
on the furniture before
let's get her bed and zip it zip it all
right now it's very important for all of
us that
shut the [ __ ] up yeah that's gonna help
her heal and all of us last thing we
want to do is hear her [ __ ] work she
needs to just lay there bed rest and if
she says one word I will come over here
and slap her uterus that's right right
doctor's orders all right and then the
Train was invented Oh No
critics of really trains thought it
would not be able to do this at all
Craig's it really trains thought quote
that women's bodies were not designed to
go at they will shatter they will
shatter into dust and I'm not I'm not
pulling punches the women will literally
evaporate in front of us their bodies
were not designed to go 50 miles an hour
it's a lot like the speed bus and their
Eunice's will fly out of their body yes
dad what you're asking for you're asking
for a water balloon fight with internal
wombs that's there after their bodies
accelerated to that speed he's using the
uteri well through pop out of the blue
out and they were a passion to other
womb yes you have exploding movies is
that what you want with your invention
of the trade if you put a bunch of women
on a train then it takes off that it's
just flying wombs everywhere listen I'm
not gonna sit by idly and watch you turn
this train into a womb explosion Factory
you foolish foolish people you've
invented something you know the power
not of women will not be able to handle
this my god would someone think about
that for once besides them every all the
men I mean not them some some people
were some critics of trains we're
worried about everybody not just Riddick
strain some people thought that any
human body would melt at high speeds
okay we've got I mean to me than this
the highlighting of all that makes more
sense now that makes more sense
oh so if we're gonna rank them melting
and then wombs flying out I'm just
saying
one of them at least is gender neutral
one of them at least allows for the
crazy to go from penises and vaginas
okay as opposed to the one where the
man's like you fools men won't melt and
neither
women but their uteri will attack each
other great if they got on the first
train and all the guy's balls flew out
you here for a good one a mum well done
you for the ladies jerking and shaking
in train cars would cause the uterus to
fall one Medical Journal said women
should not live in the suburbs because
to get home they would have to take a
streetcar or to get to and from school
young girls and their uterus would have
to take a train so is and again there's
just nobody wants to try Dumon on a
train no they I mean kids are like this
you shouldn't do this and then the rap
they do it especially the young girls go
well now you've ridden a train later in
life you're not gonna have babies think
about that train ride was worth your
life of celibacy and loneliness did you
enjoy that let me ask you this did any
of your friends melt yet oh they will
they will huh cuz I know huh cuz I'm
just assuming a New York doctor said the
railroad caused women to experience
nervous shock you've never seen anything
like it and yet this probably was never
happening anywhere builder like I've
seen it a million times
no a woman gets on the train she thinks
she's all fancy-pants and brave next
thing you know her uterus is jamming
down its throat strangling her she sits
there doesn't know what's going on
unmarried the rest of her life
hmm if I had a nickel well they they
were just gonna train if they saw a
woman crying they'd be oh it's our
uterus well I hope you're happy her
life's over The Lancet was an important
and influential medical journal in 1862
the journal journal came out against
ladies taking their wombs on trade it
may you could have just ended at it
against ladies James were harmful due to
the little jolts of an area which was
already in a tender State it said well
what the uterus is always in a tender
state according to The Lancet
is that true Medical Journal oh gosh
yeah
[Music]
mine's calloused you Dave you don't have
100 do you mean the one you're his yard
with he's just smoking cigarettes
looking at me he owes pickled yes pig
who do you choose I got it at a deli did
you hmm 58 give me a couple pickle
uteruses we only got one left
we can't so give me a pound of meat look
all righty take a bunch of meat loaf
married women were warned against
excessive traveling by train because
many women were taking long honeymoon
train trips and the journal strongly
recommended against such madness it was
clearly leading to miscarriages Oh which
miscarriages are super common so they
could easily just blame it on whatever
the [ __ ] it's linked to everything yeah
I think it's linked to sex yeah yeah
when you [ __ ] have a baby early
without know it's stopped a letter in a
surgical Journal quote the uterus is
tender don't wink see he does a little
wink at me
it is enlarged and it is somewhat
painful when any attempt is made to
replace it written by Jack Sparrow's
replace it yeah okay what are you
replacing it with I make a good fake one
hey I got meat loaf yeah you know yeah I
got a bunch of meat loaf I put it in a
ziploc bag boom you got a no womb
welcome to booming wombs boom no one huh
what do you need huh what's the matter
you got a will miss you take it tombs
got two wombs I mean we can do it too
but I'm gonna have to see the other
person the other wombs for huh who's the
other one for now both me oh you want to
do a jam in your wombs
yeah you want to do route you're talking
about a couple womb mates living inside
you all right yeah so what we do is
we're gonna take a bunch of meat loaf
okay all right we put it in a cup hey I
got a meat loaf no no no no it's all
different okay this is medical loaf Oh
gotcha yeah so we take a bunch of the
medical loaf and we put it in a couple
of the bags uh-huh
and then I medically speaking I jam it
into where you
Risa's yeah yeah and now the only
problem is you're not gonna be able to
ever ride a train what and if you want
to go on horseback you're gonna need to
you know write it while hovering and not
controlling welcome the Bowman whoops
okay so you are talking about wombs and
not rooms you know wombs isn't it no no
isn't it what is the speech impediment
of some sort fair but something even
more terrifying came I can't I can't
imagine bicycles oh no no it's like a
one-person train the wombs nemesis oh
absolutely the saddle it's designed just
to attack a wound in 1869 a newspaper
wrote about a horror scene happening in
Los Angeles quote Los Angeles has a
velocipede bike bicycle sure school for
ladies where the dear creatures are
introduced to the mysteries of the
bicycle free of charge okay so oh boy so
they found the book of black magic yeah
it's like it's like they're turning
women into monsters they just don't know
the power of what they're doing they
have no idea you fools
the daily outs of paper in 1870 quote
epidemics are fearful things
this guy's calm about two years ago we
had an epidemic of smallpox this was
followed by bicycles oh yeah which
killed about as many indirectly what
yeah is that backed up No
okay that's been in the area of the
penny farthing do you think the what the
penny farthing bicycle that wasn't that
one of the first ones there's not the
one of the big wheel yes yeah well the
wheel they called it an ordinary annuity
Marie what the regular bike they call
the big wheel one was called the
ordinary yeah okay sure that's the
normal one this is obviously the normal
bike and then here's the crazy one that
we don't see this one going very far
catching on nobody will be nobody won't
want to dismount a bike so simply so
they thought that the one with the big
wheel I think because when you pedal
that it you could
much faster because that the big wheel
sure so they there was no there was no
eating no anything there was no even
wheeled one so they just had the big
wheeled one sure and so mostly just
dudes wrote it wonder if that's where
the the big wheel for children when you
of your generation Widow came here
probably will yeah oh the big wheel
don't look at me like that I see
cigarettes on the big wheeler I mean
essentially man he did men were riding
and women wanted to know what all the
fun was about and that was fine quote as
long as they would remain spectators the
men continued injuring themselves right
yeah can't have a woman do that no
broken at will memory broken hands
broken arms are super in common because
you would fire from you would fall hit
something and then fly over sure yeah
yeah no I would imagine that the big
wheel would be more dangerous that's not
good they're difficult to control pedal
accidents happen all the time small
rocks could send someone flying but
women still wanted to ride foolish
foolish why would you do this oh no
think about what you're saying don't
understand about what you saying you
don't want to have children wouldn't you
rather sit and occasionally get [ __ ]
listen I've got a beautiful tub of water
for you to float in for the rest of your
life silently wouldn't that be heaven
yet it was not considered proper for a
lady to mount a bike like a man so the
ordinary the ordinary is hard to get on
nah right you got to climb up and do a
whole thing so I'm doing that women then
quickly soured on the bicycle and of
course they quickly soured on watching
men ride bicycles this meant men could
not have as much fun riding because
women weren't sit around watching them
so weird how that took the fun out of it
for them no you may pine for it but
never achieve now watch me fall over
this rock again look at me hello
then came the chain bicycle in the 1870s
with equal sized wheel wheels it was
named the safety bicycle okay
meaning people wouldn't fall far you
can't die I was like put old people on
it right and women right right much
easier for a woman to ride and then
cycling suddenly took off the bearings
which just was a cycling magazine quote
it knows no class distinction is within
each reach of all richer poor alike have
the opportunity to enjoy this popular
and healthful exercise so it's the great
equalizer okay I would love to get my
hands on a bike magazine from back then
to my job let's see what else they're
covering just the racism I'm sure of you
oh hey guys by the 1890s cycling was
considered a craze quote general
intoxication an eruption of exuberance
like a seismic tremor that shook the
economic and social foundations of
society and rattled the windows of its
moral outlook what was happening was
women realize bicycles could transform
their life in a major way maybe more
than any other invention in the history
of man I don't like the sound of this
one this men were losing their mind
they're like just got on a thing in
laughs all right Ted relax I think we
all know who is standing here and the
woman my what is her name my wife
doesn't matter one thing yes the woman
my wife woman we're all here for this
was a building in the bath thing that I
have over there Lauder and then I said
won't you cook and then she got up and
laughed and said [ __ ] off or something
problem is she left her womb I'm sure is
it in the tub absolutely it is don't
look in there though it'll bite your
head off like an anaconda now listen
what we need to do is realize that
unfortunately we've let women know about
something that's not ideal was this we
thought the woman would quickly learn
that her womb would get injured on the
simple bike but unfortunately they seem
to be doing something to keep their
wombs in check well think I'm obviously
thinking it's a troll under a bridge
with the staff
thank you for destroying the world we
all know what we need to do come up with
a time machine and make sure that women
never go outside Jordan I for one have
been the one pushing for the ordinance
to remove there
for decades yes you've called me crazy
no eyes ovaries legs need to go then
you've got a good stable woman just
something in a room that doesn't
recognize light versus dark going glug
all day oh my sweet blob
so actress Sarah Bernhardt said all the
women on bicycles were refusing domestic
family life susan b anthony said
bicycles had done more to emancipate
women than anything in the world it
tells you how shut in the distances have
been until this point how [ __ ] up [ __ ]
was that when you put two wheels on a
thing then they're like what happened to
the world i mean essentially you created
a woman fun bubble that just burst it's
like a market oh no they found out about
a thing oh boy
I knew we'd rue this day eventually this
would happen oh we knew this would come
this modern woman was referred to as the
new woman
she broke with convenient convention
must be gaijin convention by working
outside the home leaving the traditional
role of wife and mother or became
politically active the bike was a huge
part of this the bike changed the type
of clothing they would wear because the
corsets long heavy layered skirts of
petticoats would not hack it on a bike
sure yeah that would stain Juris so now
they put on the bloomers bloomers
bloomers are like I know they look like
onion legs I'll tell you what they are
knocking on the door of pants thank you
can't be happy needs to breathe they had
been around for a while now that
bloomers took office it's why society
argued over these pants but it was a
necessity if a woman wanted to ride a
bike when famous cyclist Annie London
Berry was in Phoenix a Annie we know
you're talking about was in Phoenix her
outfit so upset an elderly woman that
the woman ran into a nearby shop and
started screaming about the depravity of
the 19th century girl
dokie there's a it it's like a man with
a womb the New England Journal of
Medicine said it was unacceptable for
women with a uterus and ovarian tumors
to ride bikes wait what the journal
warned two women with tumors rode bikes
and their tumors became rapidly larger
wait a minute it's like Aaron - yeah the
tumor just doesn't get bigger on its own
you can just yeah no way no way this has
to be related to biking it gets bigger
and bigger and bigger
Thanks foolish women also quote women
ought not to ride during menstruation
though this writer admits that several
of his patients had done so without
injury such hunch hunch hunch but still
yeah the two lucky ones I say the bike
seat was seen as a legit problem for
ladies and their vaginas so I've had a
feeling that's good yep
don't you understand they'll never want
a man on them again why would they
they've got a bike I'm in love with my
seat Harry
you knew this day would come I love the
seat more than you does this mean I have
to learn how to [ __ ] yeah
yes but I'm yes and be nice or [ __ ] just
learn how to [ __ ] no okay medical
journals warned that the seat could be
tilted for ultimate pleasure oh my god
they have no quote riding around on
these two-wheeled [ __ ] machines filthy
[ __ ] quote in this way a girl could
buy carrying the front peak high or by
relaxing the stretched leather in order
to let it form a deep hammock like
cavity which would fit itself snugly
over her entire vulva and reach up in
front bring about constant friction this
is animated right the clitoris and labia
yeah this pressure would be much
increased by stooping forward
and the warmth generated from vigorous
exercise might further increase the
feeling I have seen the case of an
overwrought a man ceated girl of
emaciated girl of 15 whose bike saddle
was arranged so that the front part
wrote upward at an angle of about 35
degrees who stooped forward noticeably
when riding and whose actions strongly
suggested the indulgence of masturbation
Wow and so yes I masturbated and
watching her badness it so the best
parts also at some point a man had to
get on and demonstrate you see how in me
it is she's doing that and she loves
every minute of it riding and riding and
riding and riding riding and riding the
guys have hymens I don't need more but I
ride horses another doctor explained
quote if a seat is properly adjusted
this causes the clothing to press
against the clitoris thereby eliciting
and arousing feelings if hitherto either
together to unknown and unrealized by
the young maiden and painful and
debilitating uterine erosion or polyp
growths will result
I mean if you're doesn't matter now this
is science if you're is it if you have a
bike seat and and I'm gonna show you
with my hands if you have a bike seat
and then your clothing this is your legs
and your clothing is all bunched up
right here huh
that's gonna cost Paolo you mean a
cotton [ __ ] yeah it's like it's like a
[ __ ] and it's rubbing and rubbing and
rubbing and you're like that feels good
good thing I'm pretending to ride my
bike now you're full of polyps yeah
right like full of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I heard she's
full of polyps everything she says is a
lie obviously this was a concern Dave
how about this was anything not a
concern
no yeah men riding by right yeah that's
that's fine
pin trains and everything else and
probably just masturbating wherever and
you know
actively louis c.k doorways but it's
like nothing nothing wrong with the man
if the fella has needs woman unlike you
it was recommended women use a quote
hygienic saddle that's what they call
this bicycle seat bag that was a saddle
okay
so a hygienic saddle so it's basically a
seat now you may have seen these because
I didn't realize what they were until I
read this okay it's basically a seat
with like a like vid like a groove down
the middle uh-huh the middle of the seat
has a groove down it so it's got the two
sides and then a groove so so your
vagina is uh Nate I'm tempted I'm
tempted unable to do anything were it to
become aroused through that's right now
it's not being aroused by the bicycle
because the bicycle is not rubbing up
against it right but the wind
mmm reason creating the woman will be
hooked on that now too so this is
obviously it won't press upon the
external genitals the new non orgasming
bike seat market was born okay finally
let's taken off from bicycle seat adds
greatly reduces vibration the perfect
seat for a lady oh my god they're not
allowed anything okay they just have a
vibration for a little while for [ __ ]
sake the duplex ladies seat ensures ease
comfort and a graceful attitude that she
won't want to go anywhere fellas wink
wink the seat receives the weight of the
pelvic bone supporting the spine and
entirely relieving the sensitive parts
of the body from pressure of any kind
the new 10-speed no clitty absence makes
the heart grow fond a ball vibration in
the worth jointless spring by frame
bicycle has made the hearts of many warm
toward the health and pleasure giving
recreation of cycling
that's right she'll know no other
pleasure finally gentlemen ever again
we're good how do we get to where we are
well I mean with a lot of really good
thoughtful thinking and a plan that made
sense and the fact that we learn from
our mistakes
the best thing I ever heard was I
believe was to get the vote in Iceland
or may have been that that they couldn't
hold public office but they just said
we're not gonna [ __ ] any of you again
and then immediately they vote and do
whatever you want
yes then the council needs a minute to
discuss okay so they finally realized
the thing they should take away from it
they can run do they want to run stuff
what they want to do they can run it run
the country run the country we're all
freaking out Andy relax they can block
max okay I'm cool we're gonna go back
over there okay and we're gonna say okay
we hear you you think you should be able
to run and but let's make it seem like
it's not because you know from the only
other option is for us to start doing it
with each other you're acting too big
again you're gonna give away what we're
doing I don't want to [ __ ] Bobby anymore
we're done you shouldn't be [ __ ] okay
listen with cave okay let's just not
talk about you're in Bobby's cave okay
and let's just go over there and tell
them we're in but it's not because of
the sex it is we've shut up okay you're
not coming over there when we go talk
I'll stay over here yeah let him run a
little my queen bee queen or whatever
I'm not terrible master queen just I
like stop [ __ ] stop okay stop okay
just settle down and focus okay just say
whatever they want I'm not going you're
not listening to the plan just shut what
up what if they what if they what if
they take away a [ __ ] they're not
gonna do that what is happening on their
Island come on where are countries
settle down I will do anything you want
period a Medical Journal recommended
once a woman was so worked up that she
was breathing out of her mouth ha ha she
should dismount the bike and walk and
take a break she's [ __ ] it if she's
breathing from her mouth orgasm has been
achieved off Oh keep your eye on her if
she smokes while riding she's done it
doctors published damning results from
surveys to cases of vaginal discharge
one case of acute ovary inflammation
four cases of harm from excessive use
causing general fatigue in several cases
of serious of varying trouble
due to riding long distances during or
near dimensional Korey Kuhl who is the
officer in charge of pulling over to
check if there is a release oh that guy
yeah that's a are you doing sorry about
this but he's just going over there just
like did you spill anything or but it
looks like come on over here I gotta put
on my glove could you be this dismount
the bicycle yes I'm gonna go ahead and
put my hand inside of your vagina
hi why is that the first step you're
riding a bike yeah yep
now I know this is my bridge
I own the bridge I can go across the
bridge on your bike no I get to do these
things good now I am a cop plus you keep
rubbing your nose so it's not going nose
to me what you're not but I'll put a
glove on this one you already have a
glove on that one
Oh yep okay no so okay I'm not married
you just won't put that out there are
you an officer or isn't you trying to
pick up I don't know I own that con on
the bridge okay you've a minute ago you
owned the bridge do user owns Oh a vague
term do you own it nope okay I'm gonna
keep writing that if that's okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah just fine right oh let's
get my routine down working the kinks
tyoma this plan is so good so tight hey
Bob I'm a bikini inspector huh so so men
were absolutely horrified by what they
were seeing a columnist in the New York
Sunday Herald wrote of the horrors he
had seen quote I think the most vicious
thing I ever saw my life is a woman on a
bicycle
what how who is this guy who is the
person who's that the worst thing
they've ever seen I'll never forget it
she there she was gliding along fool
just riding like she owns herself her
womb was caught in the spokes
I had thought cigarette smoking was the
worst thing a woman could do but I have
changed my mind ever since then Jesus
Christ I'm smoking on a bike once how
has no one made a horror movie about
this oh my god so this is my dictation
rose this is my pitch okay uh-huh
so you're sitting on a road right movies
arts hear a noise look over woman rides
by to bicycle Fein and Fein and thing if
I am Finn Finn Finn the French the
French F know I'm aware Fein that's it
it's Finn no it's fi and it's Finn Finn
Finn why are we talking about the end of
my movie because there's nothing else to
talk about
so the so the good goes by on a bike the
good goes by a girl the late-night bike
more the one with the womb she goes by
everybody [ __ ] screams because why
fene end why are they screaming cuz the
girl goes by on a bike what's the crazy
part it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I want to make
a movie about you pitching your movie
okay okay sequel ghosts in their movie
starts a girl soon as she's movius when
you say movie starts do you mean the
movie starts or they're watching a movie
movie starts no this is the movie I'm
pitching you the goddamn you don't tell
me the movie starts when your pitch
starts let me out okay right - so
there's a rock there's a girl sitting on
the rock she likes to start smoking a
cigarette okay another girl rides by on
a bicycle okay thing that's it
it's a Finn thing movie over no it's the
French term yeah no I know I'm telling
you what it is Finn Finn Finn
yes fene movies over how about this okay
Finn pitch is over so you like it you
want to buy my movie we do not like or
we are not buying it it's a horror film
yeah it's a train wreck what was the
beginning of end she writes by normally
the middle is where we need some stuff -
and the beginning plus your end needs
work and you don't know how to say Finn
what about she talks that's interesting
now that's fascinating that is
interesting to us why can't you just say
Finnish is a French movie okay I guess
so we've got notes many yeah another
brilliant male writer quote cycling
tends to destroy the sweet simplicity of
her girlish nature besides how dreadful
it would be if by some accident she were
to fall into the arms of a strange man
yes it's like a two-wheeled juvenile
hall it will corrupt the mind
and simply as she's riding it whispers
sweet nothings into a year until she
finds a suitor more superior than you
women will ride and crash and fly into
men's arms and then they're married man
listen do you know how it works if their
brains are tiny maybe non-existent so
when they fall into something warm they
think mmm yummy stay there like a fish
yes much like a fish I love women
I also love women the second mother
Daley Union wrote that doctors began
recommending in 1895 that women ride
tricycles
Hey ladies gather on we've found a way
to be worse
hey hear us out hear us out how about
you ride around like [ __ ] baby we know
you guys are getting sick of us
condescending you about the bikes so
we've come up with a solution you're
gonna ride what we call twice a course
because your little babies don't know
what you're doing the worst I mean some
so many health problems could occur and
cause issues for the rest of woman's
life like like associating with a man
yes
cures popped up that capitalized on
fears that cycling could adjourn the
kidneys liver and urinary tract Warner's
safe cure appeared in the Chicago Times
Herald Kansas City Star among other
papers warning minor side effects from
vibrations of the wheel could eventually
lead to death what is going on gotta get
him off the bike I mean by any means
necessary necessary you're going to die
we've decided we're going to give you
all penises don't call our bluff from
the Boston Globe quote I have tried my
very best to be convinced that a woman
looks well on a bicycle she does not all
right the attitude is an ungraceful
strained one and if the writer happens
to be a fat woman her face gets liver
red and she looks distasteful oh my god
she's sweating it's horrifying
she's sweating no matter how much they
tried to look their best they have an
untidy look tumbled hair negligee caps
which means not proper hats and a
general loose get up from
stylish-looking
are from stylus okay so really the
complaint is that you're not hot that's
right and and and again okay hear me out
I'm a man yes yes so when I'm walking
down the street mm-hmm I like to see
beautiful women right this is making
that different but what if the woman is
enjoying the ride and her enjoyment
comes from maybe their appearance not
being as appealing to you as it once was
but could be again but temporarily not
where you'd like it I feel like you're
not hearing me I'm walking down the
street and I like to see beautiful
things women especially now but what if
the woman's quality of life yes is
raised by this experience she's having
on a bicycle you're not hearing me at
all it's like you're not hearing a word
that I say right not a word right it's
like talking to a wall right I want to
see pretty things I'm entitled to see
pretty things right what if we came up
with an area where no man could go and
the women could ride their bikes and
then when they what you know where they
was this hellworld
okay what place is this I was thinking
like which is a monic it sounds like
witchcraft no okay women yes always dead
oh nothing Harry Harry Harry Harry
remember the voice oh yes I'm awfully
sorry but women were Aries not a woman
women kept writing [ __ ] bicycles
obviously they were not gonna stop so
rules had to be put in place
yeah and no more women in 1895 but
getting rid of you the New York world
which was Pulitzers newspaper published
a list of don'ts for female cyclists
I've grabbed a few don't be afraid don't
faint on the road don't wear a man's cap
don't wear tight garters don't attempt a
long ride
don't coast it's dangerous though it
gods that battling don't boast of your
long rides oh well you're not supposed
to be taking them don't cultivate a
bicycle face also a strenuous face you
mean sweating yes now when you say that
don't refuse assistance up a hill okay
so no no
a man wants to help make him wear laced
boots
don't worry laced boots sorry they're
tiresome don't imagine everybody's
looking at you don't imagine everyone is
looking at you don't wear a garden party
hat with bloomers okay this one over
here well that one actually on our alpha
bike don't chew gum exercise your jaws
in private oh my god
don't ask what do you think of my
bloomers don't use bicycle slang leave
that to the boys oh really
Doug go out after dark with a male
escort what don't let your golden hair
be hanging down your back okay very a
lot of rules can I just ask yes
what would bicycle slang be you do you
think oh gosh pokes Jane Jane you're on
you're to tire yeah yeah yeah on you to
time yeah you're on you're too tired
yeah zip it by zipping by yeah licensed
by the boy not coming from you ladies
don't overdo things let cycling be a
recreation not a labor don't ignore the
laws of the road because you're a woman
yeah woman don't scream if you meet a
cow what the hell just happened
don't scream if you meet a cow that's
not a lot of this I just love that they
think women are like oh I met him you
know women are gonna start sleeping with
cows if they keep getting introduced
I've seen it happen before don't appear
in public until you've learned to ride
well yep bye and bye that just ride in
your room until you're ready to go out
on the road the constant warnings about
women could be destroyed by bikes
continued throughout the 1890s but not
all Ron board with the attacks one
Chicago Daily News article said quote
when a woman wants to learn anything or
do anything useful or even have any fun
there is always someone to solemnly
warned her that it is her duty to keep
well meanwhile in many states she can
work in factories 10 hours a day she can
stand behind the counters in badly
ventilated stores from 8 o'clock to 6
she didn't bend over the sewing machine
for 5 cents an hour and no one cares
enough to
protests yes but when these same women
find a cheap and delightful way of
getting the fresh air and exercise there
is a great hue and cry about their
physical welfare by the way if they're
so obsessed with fresh air why not let a
man just blow into their mouths all the
time thank you that's the freshest air
comes from a man not earth I'm sure they
burned this newspaper died after that oh
yeah yeah
what's the monster who wrote this we
want your head but it was over there
we're not gonna stop women from riding
bicycles and they could not put the cat
back in the back women he was sure they
could not put the animal womb back in
the bigger animal thank you the way
women rode horses changed the decline of
riding sidesaddle was finally here in
the early 1900s newspaper stories
started appearing about women riding
their horses astride one leg on each
side of the horse ah this was received
as you would expect I don't feel well
I've just seen a woman express merriment
with her legs over a horse while she
hides her hymen chattering look at her
Oh God smiling to hide the hymen pain
she's clearly in the Los Angeles Times
May 1905 quote the woman cannot throw
her leg over the back of a horse without
profaning the grace of femininity or
grasp with her separated knees the
shoulders of her mount without violating
the laws of good taste or appear in the
cross subtle without any bit of dignity
elegance or poise
well but we're making baby steps yeah we
really are babies really making progress
of course worse technology was coming
the automobile man doctors got to work
explaining the horrors of riding in cars
oh my god the ladies from the influence
of the automobile upon gynecological
conditions by dr. J Clifton Edgar quote
regarding the influence of motoring upon
the nervous systems of woman one is able
to sort them into two distinct classes
and one little disturbance is produced
in a second class of women well we found
those who can never adjust themselves
mentally to the use of the
automobile for more than short runs at
low speed a speed over 15 or 20 miles
per hour in a car causes actual mental
suffering nervous excitement and
circulatory disturbances last often
accompanied by racing heart beats
extending into the night and causing
insomnia there's two camps when it comes
to a woman an automobile or hit like
yeah the first one yeah negligible all
good you'll basically not notice much of
a difference in your woman drive about
drive about just gonna seem the same
yeah she might be the same okay
the second class yep like I said first
class nothing bad yeah the second class
her body becomes hell whoa her body
becomes a complete nightmarish health
she is in a skin prison oh Jesus that
she cannot shatter her way out of from
the car yes exactly
her heart rate explodes [ __ ] me at this
point our blood is probably leaking from
her heart going all over her womb like a
magic shell yeah she is losing her
control yeah her brain is melting her
genitalia is aroused to the point where
she is achieving some sort of satanic
orgasm the woman will without question
explode it's a matter of how much time
do you have on your hands you know the
second you see any disturbance the best
thing you can do is stop your car get
your woman out and throw her in ice
throw her in a big tub of ice now you're
a doctor I am an absolute mechanic I did
not mean to mislead you I am I car
mechanic because you're talking about
women and their bodies and a doctor I'm
a guy who knows stuff I'm a car mechanic
you're just a guy I'm a guy you know
about cars I know a lot about cars and I
also know what it does I told you one of
the camps a women will stay fine okay
yeah I'm pretty sure I know two camps
I'm not saying that you watch I met this
chicken little guy you know all the
women are gonna die they're not 78
percent of them will and they will melt
like Santa melt 78 percent of the woman
women the woman whatever you call them
they will melt like cater doctor I am a
mechanic I'm a doctor of cars but a
woman is a lot like a car no yeah
there's a lot of pieces that go in there
that's not and they don't really work no
and she's
a lot of danger no none of that is show
if she's like a car with too many parts
none of that she's like a car with no
engine and five batteries okay so he's
all jammed up
no and you sir want to take her for a
ride she will melt like a goddamn candle
you've had intercourse with a car yeah I
sleep with a lot of the cars Jesus
Christ get out of my [ __ ] house okay
your heart first of all first of all I
am a doctor no you can't be a doctor all
right I'm not a doctor but I want to
stay for dinner
come on it's mostly why did you pick
honey could you cook this nice man Emile
you're not letting us stand up are you
oh my god all of a baby partner to turn
into some sort of naming I took off her
legs Oh oh good okay I was gonna say
she's healthy very healthy mouse a
little active for my liking other
doctors responded to dr. Edwards paper a
doctor broad head quote I think that God
had mmm let me tell you what I think
quote I think dr. Eggman's paper is most
conservative certain women appear to be
especially susceptible to the
miscarriage influence of the automobile
and certain conditions within the female
pelvis appear to me to favor this women
with relaxed uterus support are
especially prone to the unfavorable
vibrations introduced by excessive
motoring yeah absolutely yes you want to
be careful in 1909 clearly tired of the
[ __ ] 22 year old Alice Ramsey drove
three female friends cross-country in 59
days oh my god what is this which helped
prove women could be trusted behind the
wheel the idea of a wandering room after
literally about two thousand years was
starting to be dispelled suddenly
doctors started coming out against the
wandering womb ah the Journal of the AMA
in 1912 quote I have seen cases of
fractured pelvis and women in none have
I ever seen a displaced uterus numerous
similar records can be collected to
prove that severe crushing injuries do
not cause displacements of the uterus
well I mean if you're gonna try to prove
something you might know find something
you don't like from an anatomical
standpoint traumatic displacements of
the uterus practically never occur
doctors have long a marveled at how the
little organ finds his way back when the
surgeon's knife is near why this sudden
change a doctor quote one of the largest
one of the largest city railway
companies informed me that this is a
frequent cause for claims of personal
injury Oh God hey what that's why
another large railway company stated
it's frivolous it had five hundred such
claims the insurance companies consulted
likewise stated that traumatic
displacements of the uterus were
frequently claimed and were among their
most difficult cases to handle yes
displace yeutter uteri uterus we're now
costing the railroads tons of and that's
why so they were like fine fine there's
no moving uterus but they still
shouldn't be allowed to do it
just cuz doctors started changing their
diagnosis because women were filing
insurance claims the doctors great now
was that in any way a tactic or were
women just sort of like it's the time we
live in let's just well back then women
had to did first of all if you want to
be independent you you could do you
could do stuff like if you were engaged
to a man and he left you you could sue
him
probably so there was a way that like
the system of capitalism allowed women
to do certain things so they wouldn't be
dependent upon the state which there was
no actually dependence on the states so
they would be tossed out right so it's a
way for them to survive essentially
right and then so now the guys are just
like no this loophole is affecting oh is
this one this is one that's not good
because this keeps them from getting now
no man controls them if they get a
payment payout from the right right the
displace uterus is now costing the
railroads money there's a sentence I
didn't think I'd hear doctors start
charging their diagnoses the displaced
uterus was starting to cause the doctor
switch was bad news for some women as
personal injury claims for traumatic
uterus displacements were being filed
against railroads frequently so the idea
of the water
Yunis was not wandering uterus was not
ended because men suddenly realized they
were being [ __ ] it was due simply to
cash and capital yeah money doctors were
coming down on the other side a doctor
CW Hopkins said 12 patients had claimed
they had a displaced uterus but none of
the claims were authentic another
surgeon said he had seen from eighty to
a hundred alleged cases but none were
displacements quote in a majority of
cases the person claiming the injury was
a malingerer
a lazy slacker kind of person okay one
of the best-known railway surgeons in
the country how I have no idea I'm dr.
John train that's so if I read this I so
want to pitch a show called railway
surgeon how are you I'm the railway
surgeon I assume because they had long
train trip so there was a doctor on the
train yeah it would make sense I guess
means the Train surgeons if you're if
you're a surgeon on a train you're just
in the booze cart bringing the hammer
down every day like what do you mean a
hernia oh [ __ ] I haven't been drinking
for this alright well let's just get the
Train milkman we have one of everything
this is Noah's Ark one of the best known
or railway surgeons in the country
stated that I'm not even the best but
I'm up there in more than 25,000 cases
accident cases he had never seen a true
displacement or prolapsed can I leave
the Train now yes please no why don't go
home the International Journal of
surgery quote if there is a good
possibility of collecting large damages
a slight fall on a railway train may be
deemed a sufficient case of displacement
of the uterus now take for instance our
present fashions it's sure bloomers
hey lady wear a tight corset and she is
almost undressed except as to that if
she has a displacement of the uterus
that can be determined by four doctors
before a jury this will gain her a
judgment they do not stop to consider
her dress and that she may be without
very much accepted corset we need to be
very careful in forming our opinions
when called for claims of an entry this
kind it's up
so I think that's going back to the cold
uterus thing that he's trying to say
that the displacements are happening
because what I mean the idea that a
corset holds your womb in place no not
in place I think it nohe much my mood
that's a well either would the idea that
your clothing like that that's what this
hay skin is nature's clothing that's
what you have on to hold these organs in
place he's like yes but still bloomers
will let the heart leak out of the mouth
quite simply I just want to say maybe we
should just let women take over for a
little while we we maybe we should take
a backseat and not do anything we just
how about we would take a backseat but
then our balls would come out of our
mouths maybe men should take a break
without question
imagine [ __ ] uh-uh so uterine
displacement was on its way out
finally name came airplanes Oh No when
the first international acquirements for
commercial pilots were proposed in 1919
female pilots were to be examined by a
doctor every three months while a man
pilot was examined every six months sure
in 1933 Aeronautics Department medical
doctor Roy whitehead began examining or
began keeping records of menstrual
abnormalities pregnancies and
miscarriages of female pilots and he
recommended female pilots not fly three
days before administration - three days
afterwards which can be up to 13 days so
pretty much half of the month dr.
Whitehead quote any women pilots have
many women pilots have fainted when
flying with fatal results of which
there's no proof whatsoever right but
again there's that p-word you wrote an
article for the journal of aviation
medicine in which he said that out of
ten female pilots killed while flying a
true mentor I double-checked there was
certainly blood on the body right how do
you there was blood then a crash was
horrific but the woman was definitely
covered in menstruation a lot of it came
from her head - a lot of head
menstruation quotable quote women are
not physically or psychologically suited
for flying or on a regular run still
women flew in October 1934 dr. Jeanette
Packard
piloted a balloon to a record altitude
5,000 of 579 feet how's your vagina I
know it but the National Geographic
Society refused to back her flight
saying they would have nothing to do
with sending a woman and mother in a
balloon into danger in 1941 the Journal
of aviation medicine publish an article
quote should women fly during the
menstrual period what I mean that is so
insane and during World War two right I
mean just imagine with our standards
today that our [ __ ] how inappropriate a
title is that it's for an article
madness and during World War two doctors
said women Air Force pilots shouldn't
fly during their menstrual cycles so why
not take this thought process into space
oh my god in 1960 dr. William Lovelace
ii hello that place here
welcome to Lovelace and Brigadier
General Donald Flickinger hi I'm the
mystery thickener thought maybe women
might be good astronauts because they
are on average smaller and lighter than
men
oh but Dave you're forgetting about that
nasty thing but Twix their lives huh yes
the bicycle seat that's right the women
in space program had begun after
rigorous testing 13 women passed the
same test as NASA's astronaut selection
process there's one problem the group
was then told they would be going to the
naval school of aviation medicine in
Florida to undergo advanced Aero medical
examinations using military equipment
and jet aircraft so this is on a
military base okay
two of the women quit their jobs to
attend but just days before they were to
report the Navy said it would not allow
the use of their facilities and the
program was immediately over okay good a
year later Soviet cosmonaut valentina
Tereshkova became the first woman in
space she somehow able to stop period
with her mind keep control of it
she actually push it there's no way
she's a woman she absolutely woman she's
not a woman she a woman goes into space
she progressed in a period the woman
goes into space when when the aircraft
comes back down and you take off the top
of that aircraft blood shoots out nice
but
she's a strong Soviet woman man no she's
a woman with a penis no she's strong
Soviet women she able to say to her body
okay buddy I know you won't have period
can we wait six months and then we have
one really big period no that's not what
happened yes that is exactly what she do
women explode
you see American women explode no all
women you know not all women you can't
control your apparatus down there yeah I
we are anything it's like an animal in
an atom she trained for years to be able
to control apparatus down enormous
whether you see a six month eight six
month period the end of six month she
had one terrible period she cried the
whole time she eats so much chocolate
ice cream all she do is talk about how
much she missed boyfriend but we are
able to send her in space so yes she's a
weak woman
of course she weak woman she woman but
she able to postpone the weak woman this
for a little while to get job done
through Soviet army foolish mean it's
like you have no gynecologist in America
we got a lot how do you think our women
can't ride horses or trains
well because they'll explode we're not
idiots we all believe in the same
science thick night finally father got
in common ground yes that's right
plus we understand we are headed off to
America best trained surgeon in the
world Thank You number one for train sir
you yes without question so the u.s.
went the other way as the car Soviets so
that all they need is for the Russians
to go up and do it once they're like
women get up there nope
oh no they were like by 1964 the women
in space program with zero evidence
stated that putting quote a
temperamental psycho physiological woman
they're calling a hormonal woman is what
they're saying there are a woman
together with a complicated machine it's
not suggested okay right because yeah
yeah yeah it's say that women would have
to time her flight to recycle to avoid
issues and that was not possible it's
impossible others said - we really
figured hey we do others said
microgravity might increase the
incidence of retrograde menstruation
absolutely which is
I think yes it might flow up the
fallopian tubes into the abdomen causing
health problems this is based on nothing
no believe it or not you'll get her up
there and show be a blood geyser just
fountain in blood out of our mouths no
one had done any experienced experiments
whatsoever then you have a gut instinct
quarter refuted by the mid-1960s NASA
wasn't open to women since the
requirements for astronauts stipulated
that they'd be military test pilots this
excluded women until 1978 when we're
chimps allowed to go that had to be by
now for short like in late 50s 20 years
after the Soviets in 8 1983 Sally Ride
became the first American woman in space
sally quote I remember the engineer's
trying to decide how many tampons should
be packed oh my god on a one-week flight
they asked is a hundred the right number
hi Sally how are you where the geniuses
from NASA so how many tampons for your
vagina enough we recommend hundred do
you know what books are yeah books we
read a bunch of books biology books and
stuff you get actually just yeah yeah
but but the difference is your vagina is
going to space and without being too
intrusive how many of these cotton
things do you need for it when you put
one in your ass well but one in your
nose your other nose yeah I put it one
of your eye yeah I think space is
already starting to affect or she thinks
that we need them Sally will just put a
thousand in here okay that's good and
put them in your vagina when you get up
there cuz your Bloods gonna go crazy
good she's become a real jerk they have
now but a lot of women in space turns
out no problems with menstruating just
like no problem with the wombs on horses
and bikes and cars and trains women are
still not allowed on submarines in the
Navy the excuse being sleeping and
privacy arrangements a large part of
that argument was the lack of an area
for gynecological exams so we've really
advanced there
okay if they put it in a thought about a
submarine surgeon but addendum epilogue
we call it the evolution sure
in 2010 Jian Franko Casper president of
the International Ski Federation said on
ESPN that the female uterus might burst
upon landing from a ski jump holy [ __ ]
online headline February 14 2014
quote first women's Olympic ski jumping
competition completed without a single
uterus explosion boy but talk about a
rating spike anyway men men men men men
men
[Music]
what other we're great what
at what point when you're wrong all the
time does it start just do we say we
don't value your opinion on women's but
can you imagine like the the like if
you're a dude and you were like imma
dude but if it back then we were dude
and you're like what but this is still
on yeah oh well don't you think a lot of
this um is sort of happening today here
no no reverting we know in what way this
regime hunter person yeah well what a
lot of there's a Jordan Peterson if
Jason Peterson is a big he's getting
Toronto professor he's becoming huge and
it's tons of this kind of [ __ ] and he's
like he's like talking about forced
monogamy and like there's this is a big
thing that's coming back well another
thing I mean what is definitely a trend
that is back now is that your science
has no value and if someone just says
something's true because they believe it
that's enough
or if someone just says that something's
true and it isn't but they say it enough
that's enough but I was thinking in
particular about you know what's going
on with the government here to the
Supreme
it's reverting yeah is it a night it is
like a regime you're talking about how
five white guys gonna take away the
woman's right to choose
yeah it's a 20-year orchestrated camp
and you hear what you're saying and you
feel that some of that is happening
right now it is just it's being turned
back instead of going that's forward
yeah yeah but that's a good thing yeah
men are great yeah cuz then it means
you're Supreme Leader Oh mom you keep
saying that and you're acting like yeah
I'm an emperor yeah floating baby Trump
yeah yeah you do have a queen we have a
queen they should just those floating
baby Trump's ever everywhere yeah what
is going on a world tour oh yeah so
that's cool yeah yeah big Floyd and baby
Trump it's the new Pink Floyd concept
album boy anything else no what a
nightmare
yep it just never ends no all right well
we tried a sign we signed cars we still
will ughter ughter we do not sign you
know design universes well actually
we'll sign a car as long as a woman as
it inaudible all right okay thank you
mom thank you add you're here for
something so sweet most enjoyable yes
most enjoyable thank you